cette za de la n'aura pas fait les gros
titres des médias
elle ne concerne que quelques hectares
et les militants qui la défendent ne
prête pas à des fantasmes du genre black
block est pourtant là aussi les
défenseurs des zones naturelles viennent
de gagner une bataille décathlon a
annoncé officiellement retiré son projet
d'une zone commerciale autour du sport à
saint jean de braye
après six ans de bataille juridique et
d'action sur le terrain l'association
splf 45 pour un site préservé entre
loire et forest aura donc obtenu que le
lieu dit l'habit sonnerie reste pour le
moment une zone humide
c'est quelque chose qui est absolument
qui abrite des espèces qui sont qui sont
endémiques que vous ne trouvez pas
ailleurs c'est une zone qui a un grand
rôle au niveau hydrologique donc qui va
assurer à une sorte d' espaces tampons
qu'il ya des grandes précipitations qui
va sur une épuration des eaux de ce sont
vraiment des zones qui ont un fort
intérêt environnemental
la mairie de saint jean de braye était
porteuse de ce projet avec décathlon et
le groupe heuliez absent aujourd'hui son
maire le socialiste david thiberge
exprimé dans la presse son regret que
240 emplois prévus soit ainsi rendue
impossible
finalement des exemples des projets de
grandes surfaces comme ça sont en fait
des destructions nettes d'emplois
puisqu'on annonce toujours ceux qui sont
créés sur site mais pas ceux qui sont
détruits par ailleurs ce soit dans les
grandes surfaces concurrentes ou dans
les petits commerces qui ferment
toujours en silence ou encore les
emplois agricoles qui seront détruits
sur le site mais c'est seulement une
bataille qui vient de se terminer ainsi
une autre à venir n'est pas exclue
puisque la mairie affirme maintenir sa
volonté de transformer un jour cette
zone naturelle agricole en zone
d'activité économique